this is a milestone for him to even  travel so no baby steps but this is a  big one this is a huge step for him  Lamar Odom makes a huge step in his  recovery leaving la to attend a Kanye  West fashion show in New York ET sat  down with Kris Jenner Thursday morning  ahead of the big event I think it was a  great thing for him to be with the  family and come out and do something  that we were all a part of and he really  wanted to support Kanye and really  wanted to be here for him because Kanye  was very instrumental in part of his  recovery Kanye would go to the hospital  and play him music and that's what he  really really responded to like he was  amazing Lamar started you know rapping  again before he could talk Khloe is such  a you know angel and has been so